I wish I could be a Disney princess so I
could marry a homeless Arabian man
I wish I could be a Disney princess so I
could have furniture is my only friends
and I wish I could be a Disney princess
so I could fight the mondo
[Music]
I wish I could be a Disney princess so I
could live with seven tiny man
Disney Princess but I would have
everything at my fingertips I can be
Native American
if I were a Disney Princess I can try
saving
I can rise
my dears jazz
I wanna be your Cinderella
I just don't want to be the part of your
life where
[Applause]
focus I wanna be you Ariel I wanna be
you so I
with joy
I wish I could be a Disney princess so I
can marry some guy who kisses me as eyes
[Music]
and I wish I could be in Disney Princess
so I could be afraid of baking guys cuz
I don't want to kill my sister Alex do
you want to play with me no okay I wish
I could be a Disney Princess so I can
have a man I wish I could be a Disney
Princess so I could
force mice I really want horse my
yeah
[Music]
I want to be a Disney princess and if I
were I take no recess to spread the
warmth and love it's the best way to
live your life might be a handsome man's
wife and we'd kiss
yes I wish I could be a Disney princess
so I could marry all this Arabian
you
[Music]